[Music]
welcome to leadership for society
reimagining work post covid i'm brian
lowery and today we're talking about
education citizens and workers education
and capitalist democracy and i'm really
excited to talk to
um two distinct guests um rachel carlson
the co-founder and ceo of guild
education um rachel um is the co-founder
and ceo of guild and their company is on
a mission to unlock opportunity for
america's workforce through education
and upskilling
and i'm also talking to david osborne
david is author or co-author of six
non-fiction books including reinventing
america's schools creating a 21st
century school system and reinventing
government a new york times bestseller
in 1992. so thanks for having thanks for
coming
great so i'm just going to jump right in
as we think about reimagining work post
covid
we have to think about education and
training right so there's we to have a
healthy economy to have a
well-functioning society we have to
train people to be able to do jobs and
also to engage in democracy in a
compelling and competent way so the
question i have for you two is
how do you think about the function of
education in our society where do you
place the emphasis so i'll david i'll
start with you
well you know that's
that's a subject of a lot of dispute in
american society people have different
views about that the way i look at it
education
has
two big missions
one is to help everyone
develop in a way that they can live
their own life to the fullest to realize
their fullest potential
and the other is to help them develop
the skills and knowledge to be
successful in a modern economy
um i think it's those two things are
you know there are other other things we
need from education as well it would be
really nice if the schools were
preparing people to be
uh productive citizens in a in a
democracy um they often fail on that
score
uh as we've seen in in recent years but
um
i think those are the those are the two
that i emphasized
rachel what about you
yeah you know my views on this have
changed quite a bit um
i joke that i was sort of bored on third
base i'm uh i was grateful to go to
stanford undergrad but i'm a legacy and
make no illusions about the fact that
i'm i'm clear why i got the leg up i
stood on shoulders right um
and so i really thought it was more
about
call it the some of the broader debates
that happen tied to the uh educated
civic population and self-actualization
i've actually been able to see a path
through a lot of that debate now which
is and much to how david described it i
think if we view education as a bit more
like a maslow's hierarchy of needs
there's a ground floor that we have to
provide people and that ground floor has
to start with the ability to provide for
my family or know that i one day will be
able to provide for my family
and that's so rooted in the american
ethos and the next level is i want to do
better than my parents did right that
that's the second part of the american
ethos of how we think about the american
dream and doing better
and and being more capable or
ability to have more flexibility or the
middle class family sustaining wage then
above that what happens is people who
after they solve for those two things
which makes all the sense in the world
from a maslow's perspective well then
they want to learn more to think about
how can they be an engaged citizen how
can they be a contributing member of
their community you see people then
return to and really embrace a lifelong
learning perspective so that's my world
view today
got it nice
yeah no that isn't a really compelling
way to put it which makes me think of
something though i was i'm impressed
that you um
are willing to say hey you know i was a
legacy i don't have any illusions around
that i think that's often an
uncomfortable thing to say and i wonder
what it makes you think about um
education as a way to maintain things as
they are right so we typically think
about education as a way to improve
the functioning of society i wonder as
you
uh given that comment
if you think about how it might
actually maintain things as they are
oh man yeah we're okay we'll go deep
early because i have a lot of feelings
about this i obviously i spend my day
today helping america's front line
workers have access to education so i
obviously spend a lot of my time trying
to disrupt the barriers that i'd argue
are heavily oriented around maintenance
but it i think
part of the important thing to
acknowledge though is that nobody's
trying to do wrong i spent a couple
years really deep in the community
college system and what i saw there was
you know
our community colleges have an average
graduation rate of 8 to 20 percent
depending on the school and how you
slice the data but i never met a bad
person working at one of those schools i
met people who were
deeply dedicated to the mission and the
work the problem is we built those
schools for a mission in the 50s and 60s
which was sending our young
men
to school after a war and creating
purpose and meaning for that crowd tied
to an economic need then so there's an
example and then you know the and i
think we don't talk enough about that
one and then i'll jump right into the
hotbed that the new york times would you
know write a story about every day if
they could which is you know the the
preservation of different types of
privilege
what bothered me a lot in my year
working in admissions and by the way i'm
a proud stanford alum i should say that
and i think we need to keep changing
right and in my year working in stanford
admissions
it was frustrating to see that there
were some elements of diversity that the
school was able to
push boundaries on and others which had
financial implications including
welcoming in more folks from the
community college system or just 18 year
olds from low income backgrounds that
that was a harder choice to make um when
you looked at
aggregate data and so i
i think there is a lot of maintenance
maintenance of an outdated higher ed
system maintenance of privilege um
and we gotta we gotta change that if we
wanna have a united citizenship back to
the goal if education wants to be
productive towards the ends of united
citizenship i think the root of our
populism right now is really really
connected to some of the flaws of our
education system
um i like that you referenced the
creation of the community college system
in part in response to the needs uh
associated with being bringing soldiers
back from the war and i'd like to think
about what the pandemic so these these
major events in history shift or can
shift how how the society functions
and so as we think about the pandemic
what have we learned about what we need
in terms of education and training what
is it revealed maybe that was there that
we weren't paying enough attention to
and david i'll go to you with that
yeah i think it's been incredibly
revealing um
i think a lot of parents in particular
were shocked
shocked first by how rigid their school
systems were and how difficult it was
for them to adjust when the world
changed and suddenly they had to go
remote
and then by the low quality of the
education their children were getting
when they were remote
um
you know we
the community college system may have
been built for the 1950s and 1960s but
the k-12 system was built for night the
1910s and 20s
it was really built
as as an industrial economy emerged
and
you know the model it was built on the
modern model at the time which was
called bureaucracy
these top-down hierarchical large
centralized bureaucracies and in the
public sector they had monopoly status
they were built to be very stable
to give you the same thing this year you
got last year and the year before and
the year before that and they're very
hard to change
in the 50s and 60s and 70s they
unionized
in most of america and that made them
even more rigid and so
now i think people have realized my
goodness we need
schools that can change and that can use
technology
and we don't have them
we have a system that is almost
incapable of change
on top of that people realized you know
our kids are all different and they need
to some of them thrive in remote
uh online education and some of them
it doesn't work at all
some of them need the social interaction
and so all kinds of families began
trying to create pods and
micro schools
grew up and all kinds of alternatives
because
we need choices for different kids and
when you have a monolithic system that
kind of treats all the kids the same and
batch processes them like they're on an
assembly line it
people are finally waking up to realize
that doesn't work so
i hope it's some kind of turning point
ryan if i could add on that in the
higher ed space we saw the most
fascinating uh segmentation of two
things that people had bundled into one
for a long time right what is college
and what we saw was that people who are
hiring i like to think of the student as
a consumer
people who are hiring college for a
coming of age experience were devastated
right there was no social emotional
learning the dorm experience learning
how to become an adult all those things
that are really intrinsic for the 27
percent of american learners who ever
spend a night in a dorm for the other 73
percent it was so empowering suddenly
they didn't have to take the bus to get
to a local campus in order to sit in
front of a faculty member who spoke for
an hour and a half and then try and get
their way home or organize that around
their work schedule suddenly there was
this blossoming of what they were hiring
college for which was skills acquisition
and so i think that's been something
that's been really really fascinating is
we're in the same way that k-12 is
um getting to have a conversation about
well what does the student need from
this system we're finding that um folks
over the age of 22 are saying wow
college suddenly started being more what
i wanted college to be
and so
the barriers that you pointed out i
think my understanding is that guild is
in part an attempt to get beyond some of
those barriers for people beyond i mean
working age people is can you tell us a
little bit about about your thinking
about that in guild how it works in
guild
yeah so our our focused demographic are
the 100 million americans for whom we
believe in the labor data tells us are
going to need to re-skill our up skill
in the next 10 years in order to
remain employable and ideally if we do
our jobs have a really good chance at a
stable family sustaining wage and career
and so the way we go about that is uh
aiming to work with uh about 300 of the
7 500 schools in the u.s
that we found have high quality low-cost
outcomes for working adults i wish that
number was bigger but 300 is enough and
they're growing so um we work with those
schools to help uh
any employee at companies that we
partner with like
chipotle or
discover financial or lowe's or disney
you name it but mostly frontline workers
across the u.s to figure out how to
figure out what are their skills today
what do they want out of their career
path in the future a conversation many
have never had the privilege of having
then what skills do they then need to
acquire to get on that path and
uh 50 of that time the answer is getting
into a degree program but 50 percent of
the time it's things like
certificates in digital marketing for
people who've been in analog marketing
frontline jobs for a long time or
helping people move from being i'm a
data entry associate to actually
becoming a data analyst or actually the
biggest one is people management the
fastest paths of the middle class right
now is teaching someone how to lead
other people so a lot of short-term kind
of six to 12-month programs and then we
just give them a a coach and advisor all
the way through um which is the the core
insight we had coming out of the
community college system was that the
best thing you can do is pair someone
with a coach got it and so there seems
to be a um working with the businesses
to make this happen and i always one of
the things that i'm really interested in
is the
the rel the respective role of business
and government and providing things like
education right so a
big social need
should business be
such a big player in this space
i can argue both ways so i'll tell you
my thoughts um the fun thing is that
guild was a was my graduate school
research project so i've looked at it
from every angle and i've sort of maybe
annoyed my investors from time to time
for doing this but i can criticize it as
well as i can support it um
i think that on one angle uh the body
was the unit of production for a really
long time and that's what got us focused
on having making sure that employers
were caring for people's physicality and
their bodies now i think that went too
far when we said should employers be the
only place where people get health care
right but i do believe employers should
should care about their workers
physicality when that was the unit of
production today the unit of production
is the brain right we're in a knowledge
economy and so i think it makes a ton of
sense for employers to have a voice in
saying here's what the future of work
looks like and we have both data
self-sourced from university presidents
who say they trust employers more now to
say what the future of work looks like
than they can figure out at their own
school but more importantly um average
american now would trust their ceo more
than their local college president to
tell them what skills they need 10 years
from now so that's the role
that's the role of informing and and
giving influence on the learning which
i'm very supportive of when it comes to
funding
we're
vehemently anti-student debt at guild
and so the path to avoiding that has
been having employers pay
i like a world where employers and the
federal government pay and i don't think
we're paying enough out of the federal
government so i i think that's where if
the world changes guild will be very
happy to adapt
great adam david if you have any
thoughts about this i mean i know that
you think a lot about schools i'd love
to hear your thoughts
well i think
i think the reality is that business
does have a huge role
in
education broadly defined if if you
think about the training and education
that people get post college or post
high school if they don't go to college
who provides most of it
businesses to their
employees and you know people in
government tend to think about well we
should
we should have this program and we
should have that program and
there are
something like 50 different programs
funded by the federal government most of
them small
but
what they really should be thinking
about is
most of the money is spent by business
and our role should be to give people
the information they need about the
quality of different providers so that
they can make better decisions about
buying
training or education
and then
as rachel said providing funds for
individuals workers and those who want
to be in the workforce so that they can
access
quality training and education
because
low-income people don't have access to
those resources
so
you know we have to understand that that
there's a market for education and
training and most of the providers are
businesses
and that's the world we live in
so let's figure out how to make it work
better for people
yeah i'm really interested in how we
make it work better because rachel you
pointed out that um
healthcare is tied to employment in part
as you described it because the body was
the unit of production right and what do
we really want to go to a world where we
have the same kind of thing for
knowledge like i don't know like i'm not
sure that sounds like a better world
than the world we're in now so how do
you how do you avoid
getting to a place where
education is incredibly tied up in
private industry as opposed to something
that society
takes care of across the lifespan
so i think about it the way our students
talk about it so um
i got to walk into stanford with a bunch
of ap credits because i went to a high
school system and i followed the
traditional path
but our average student is in their 30s
often a woman often a mom often a woman
of color and she has often received
enormous amount of training at her
company and yet our higher ed system
kind of puts its nose up to that
learning that she's done over often
you know call it 10 to 14 years whereas
i got i mean
i had good high school teachers but
let's be honest like did i really have
12 credits of college learning the day i
walked into stanford i don't think so
and but we honor it right so we create
systems that honor one population and
it's typically populations that follow
the traditional norm which then doubles
down on privilege and eliminates access
so i think what higher ed needs to do is
open up the doors to honoring more
learning the uncomfortable truth in that
is that it's problematic for a higher
ed's revenue model because higher ed
today has very high cost of acquisition
very very high the top 100 don't but the
other 7 400 schools in the us pay a
tremendous amount to google and facebook
and digital marketing to attract their
students
and then they have to receive enough
revenue on the back end to make that
investment worth it so short-term
programs are very threatening to
universities but also so is giving away
credits for free now again elite schools
can do it
but we've not
said we would honor the learning that
happens on the job and i think i think
business wants that and i think higher
ed is resisting that
great so i also i want to shift it a
little bit from higher ed and think
about
primary school
so
as i assume many of you and listening
know and i'm sure rachel and david you
know that there are huge disparities and
outcomes
along
certainly among dimensions of race but
class as well
in terms of educational achievement
reading
math and then we also see across all
different demographic groups
as
as someone pointed out a stunning and
dismaned consistency and misinformation
around civic education like our
citizenry just does not understand how
our government functions
why is this like what do you think is
causing the failure um and i'll it out
i'll go to you and i know you've already
talked about how it's an old system
but the old system was designed to teach
people to read and write in math and
we're failing at that too so what do you
think is going on here
yeah i think that
we created this system which as i said
is very stable and uh you know schools
today are not all that different from
they were when i was going to school 50
years ago
um
they assume
that students come to school motivated
and then the teachers will provide
knowledge to them
and that still works in a lot of middle
and upper middle class communities
because many of those students do
come to school motivated
and they manage to get an education
but
in the inner city and in some rural
areas with really low income kids
you can't make that assumption they may
not even come to school speaking english
um
they may come to they may grow up in a
neighborhood where they don't know
anyone except their teachers who ever
went to college and it's never occurred
to them that they would ever go to
college
and so what happens is they do they do
okay through elementary school typically
but then you hit middle school and you
start introducing abstractions and
asking them to learn things like algebra
and why would you ever learn algebra
unless you saw it as a step toward
college or a step sort of career
and if they don't see that
they motivate you know the motivation
isn't there and they fall off the
conveyor belt and you see high dropout
rates and
and so on um
we need schools that meet those kids
where they are
the first job is to create motivation
it's interesting you know we've created
a
innovation sector in public education
called charter schools
and they work
well in some places and not as well in
others a lot depends on the state law
that governs them and a lot depends on
whether they're authorized by a school
district or a state board or a
university
but
where they work well
when you visit one of these schools
they'll immediately tell you yeah on day
one our job is motivation
we bring the kids in let's say we're a
high school we bring them in in ninth
grade for two weeks before school starts
and it's all focused on building
motivation
building expectations
then we tailor to where they are we
don't just give them this the classic
ninth grade curriculum and if they're
ready for it great and if they're not
too bad
um
we meet them where they are we provide
tutors if they need to catch up we
provide extra time in the summer and
during breaks if they need to catch up
you know the word the cliche has become
personalization but we really do need to
go from batch processing to
personalizing education
and helping each student go from where
they are when they get to school to
where they need to be
and the old system can't do it
it's just impossible it's so rule-driven
and so rigid um
and so built really for the convenience
of the adults
not for the needs of the children
uh that we need fundamental change in
how that system operates
and rachel i know this is not your space
but i'm just curious if you have
thoughts i know you i mean again you
spend a lot of time thinking about
education
um what do you see um as a possibility
in terms of improving outcomes
yeah i um i can't profess to be an
expert i kind of sit on the barbells
because i spend my time in higher ed and
then we run a preschool daycare at guild
so i spend a lot of time thinking about
innovation in child care which by the
way
that's another mess for another day it's
worse than k-12 some not a bad day um
but in the k-12 space
i think one of the things we've lost our
way on
especially amidst the movement to send
everybody to college which i'm
culturally very supportive of i think we
have to define what college means but
i'm kind of culturally supportive of
where that came from and the the moving
away from a culture that tracked people
based on race and socio-economic
background but when we shifted to this
world of where about 10 percent of
americans went to college to where that
was supposed to be the aspiration for
everyone what we forgot to say was okay
so how do we want to
measure that and we got really obsessed
with basically the memorization of
content
right like so much of our k-12 system is
around trying to get you to memorize and
accumulate knowledge
but we've computers and i'm pretty sure
my kids are going to use
a search engine and a calculator 3x more
than i did and 30x more than their
grandparents did so i'm pretty sure for
my kids the measurement is going to be
do they love learning and do they love
it enough to constantly contextualize
the knowledge they're learning and i
don't think any of those tests that can
measure whether they've memorized
anything or really going to matter and
i'd probably fail my seventh grade
algebra quiz if i retook it right now
but i was able to build on top of that
learning to do the things i do today and
we kind of have to reset i just think we
have to reset the conversation because
to do the social emotional learning to
care for people to do what actually i
think some of the system did better
believe it or not in the 20s 30s and 40s
not for everyone by a long stretch but
what the system did well for at least
the middle class white male
was not about memorizing content it was
about providing a platform to become the
type of adult society wanted you to
become
and so these are these are all great
aspirations but as as you both know
better than almost anyone there are a
lot of barriers to making these changes
um and i'm going to come back to
something that you said earlier david
that um
unions you mentioned as as one barrier
to change
um and that's actually is a big part of
the conversation we talk about education
teachers unions are particularly
powerful
um but they also are a way presumably to
protect labor right so our teachers
aren't paid very well and it unless i
looked at a 2013 study that suggested
that charter schools do teachers are
paid less than traditional public school
teachers so as you think about
making these kind of changes how what do
you tell though that workforce those the
current teachers um primary secondary
school
about what they can expect
from these changes
well i think that
you know that in many ways the teachers
are the most disillusioned part of this
whole picture
um
teachers in public school systems
gallup does a survey he's done it
millions of times
for all kinds of businesses and
professions
i think they've
there are about a dozen professions that
they've surveyed
and one of the questions it's i forget
it's 20 questions or 16 questions one of
the questions is um
i feel that my voice my opinions matter
at work most of the time
and
of all those professions education is
the highest in saying no to that
teachers public school teachers feel
like that their bottom up they're that
they're at the bottom of the barrel and
they have
outside their school classroom they have
little authority they have no control
over sort of the direction of the school
and
their complaints sort of boil down to
they treat us like children
we need to make education a profession
and and in a profession you have some
role in helping to
manage helping to run the institution
um
we
you know we unionized the teachers
unionized for good reasons back in the
60s and 70s it was needed uh women in
particular were just treated terribly
you get you know back in the 50s if you
got pregnant as a teacher you you were
out
just
so
we needed
all of those changes
but now we need to move away from a
model that's built on an industrial
workforce management versus labor
to a more professional model where the
teachers are part of the team that runs
the school
and that's that's a tough shift
it's happening there are about
150 teacher-run school public schools in
this country about half of them charter
half of them district
and they're growing slowly
but
all of the
status quo all of the forces that
preserve the status quo in k-12
education stand in the way of that and
and one of them is teachers unions
they actually don't want teachers
treated like professionals
they don't want
teachers to be able to
move from school to school
as they choose
they want districts preserved as they
are
to preserve the cert the the protections
that teachers have
for example the fact that they after the
first two or three years it's almost
impossible to fire them i mean that's
very important to the teachers unions
um
and that that creates so much rigidity
in the system
um and undermines the ability to
make schools improve year after year
after year
you know my mom's a school schoolteacher
by the way and she was um quite
frustrated as most
primary school teachers uh are and can
be um but i think she also
appreciated the the protections right so
i think there's a lot of distrust in the
people who are making decisions about
how resources are expended
and the union is a way to have
voice right it's obviously a collective
voice
i i wonder how do you change the system
such that you maintain like i i hear you
saying that they should be treated like
professionals they should have a role in
running things that is not at all i
would argue how it currently functions
right right and so if you if you get rid
of unions prior to making that change
right then you you put teachers at risk
so i just wonder how do you think about
that chicken and neck problem
we need we need to preserve certain
protections
so for example
if
if you're in a school district
you should be protected from the whim of
an administrator
firing
right there should be due process there
should be a process
when i was a consultant our firm
actually was hired to
run the minneapolis school system for
three and a half years back in the 1990s
they actually wanted to hire our
president
but he wouldn't leave the company he
just founded and so they hired the
company
and one thing that he and his colleagues
managed to do was work with the union in
minneapolis to develop a teacher-run
system to weeding out teachers who
shouldn't be in the classroom
we can do that
it means modifying the 10-year system
not eliminating it completely
the same with
if we
if we change our school system so that
principals and their teachers have more
power to actually
operate the school and change the
learning model to meet the needs of the
kids who've shown up at that school
then
teachers need more
some teachers won't fit this school or
that let's say this school decides to
become a dual language immersion school
because there's a lot of
spanish-speaking kids
um
and it's far more effective in that
environment well some teachers won't be
won't speak spanish and they won't
they'll lose their job at that school
but a district can say you're not going
to lose your job
we're going to let you choose
a place at a school that will fit you
better with the principal who wants you
but is not a dual language immersion
school
so there are
there are ways we can create more
flexible systems while
continuing
some legitimate and very fair and common
sense protections for teachers and
frankly teachers welcome that
um
they are very frustrated if you read any
of the surveys
yeah i think there's not a lot of um
disagreement with that there's this
frustrating being a teacher these days
for sure i want to kind of shift back to
thinking on the student side and the
later stage in life we we don't have a
lot of in this country vocational
training
um and so this is obviously it's coming
to going to be for you rachel
um
and by vocational training i don't mean
like the what people think of as like
plumbers or electricians though you know
the kind of basic trades but i mean
vocational training that could be
um even like tech and engineering like
we we have a
university system and then people go out
and often really learn what they need to
do at the job right that is a common i
think experience
how do we address the historic
inequities in that kind of training and
for you rachel so it's i think now
people say oh it's a pipeline issue but
the reality is when the the great jobs
were factory jobs there were still
racial and gender inequities then too
right so it's not as if these inequities
are new because we've now moved to this
acknowledged economy those the
inequities that we have now are the same
negatives we had before in terms of
access to the best paying jobs
and so as you think about what you're
doing the way you're trying to upskill
and prepare people for these
array of jobs how do you address that
historic inequity that continues
yeah so at one level just to brought
like because this is a philosophical
environment i feel like i can go dork on
history here part of why
america has fewer
i'll call it technical invocation right
because we called it technical skulls
until we started using tech for another
word um is we have a really
heterogeneous economy
and that's actually great right so when
you look at the countries that have
really successful apprenticeship and
technical trainings whether that's
moving people into the what's called the
historical trades which i'm really
passionate about or moving people into
let's call it the 21st century technical
trades um companies doing that well have
really homogeneous economies and so the
government and business tend to align on
like okay what are our five things like
there are countries in europe who are
like we're a car manufacturing country
and others who are like we make cheese
and chocolate right like that's actually
a thing america for good it's part of
why our gdp grows we're heterogeneous so
if you're going to then try and do
something that creates the opportunity
what we used to do is we did it
regionally and the us had a very
regional economy for horrible reasons
mostly connected to slavery and then the
way we grew but now we have a national
heterogeneous economy so you have to
start there when you're talking to
anyone who lives anywhere in the us they
don't want to feel constrained to what
their pathways can be based on the
region they grew up in or to your
question their background so then the
next question we often talk a lot about
is okay how do we actually do this in
the right order and my main thing that i
think we need to do is that we need to
actually flip the order of learning
today we say oh go get your general
studies go learn about critical thinking
and all these things and then we'll
teach you some technical skills maybe in
your senior year or better yet
i'll pick on stanford for a second here
we don't have a business degree if you
want that you come back for graduate
school
and and hook line and sinker i did it
but um
that's a problem i think we should teach
people the technical skills first that
allows them to enter the workforce and
we need to recognize that we're now in a
lifelong learning economy and how do we
stack the learning on and if you change
that conversation you suddenly open the
door to acquiring those technical skills
to people
in a lot more equitable ways and so what
i say a lot is like why do you have to
go to college to get a job why can't you
get a job
learn and then decide what you want to
do in college
all right that is a that is a a very
different system
there you go
no you nodded when i said can i go
philosophical yeah of course no i i love
that
david our government funding has to
shift as well you know we're stuck in
this exactly what rachel said this
mindset that you go to college well
so
you know even our most progressive
leaders
like bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
you know they're all for free college
but what percent of americans go to
college what percent of americans stay
in college for four years
it's a minority
most americans don't so you're leaving
them out you're going to spend all this
money on people who are already
a little bit privileged
i have proposed uh not that anyone's
listening but um
we should take that money
and why don't we say
anybody who's making has an income today
of less than eighty thousand dollars a
year
let's give them an account a lifelong
learning account
let's start with
ten thousand dollars
and maybe we'll have a sliding scale and
maybe it'll be at 80 000 it'll be 5 000
and down to when you make 70 000 it'll
be 10 000. i mean so so it phases out
slowly but but the point is let's give
everybody resources that they can use
and if they want to use that to go to
community college great if they want to
use that to help pay for a four-year
college great but if they're already in
the workforce
and they know they need certain skills
fine go you know go at night and get a
certificate or
use the money how
you
need it to improve your skills and your
education at your point of life and
let's make it available for
the bottom half of our income scale not
the top half
all right so you got to jump on my last
question so i'll go i'll go with rachel
let's see if you have another something
else you want to add but um this this
whole series is about reimagining work
so
how do you what would you do if you
could reimagine the way education
functions and work what would be your
primary focus what would you like to
change
yeah so david hit it but i the 4 in 40
is dead right going to college for four
years and then going to work for 40 and
then retiring
dead
i think we're entering what i call like
the every four
which is that we're going to work and
every four to five years we're going to
need to pick our heads up and either
re-skill meaning prepare for our next
job or upskill get better at today's job
that we're in and what the data tells us
is that white people who start in their
career in the white collar economy
earlier are going to do more upskilling
and unfortunately people who live in the
lower half of the economy are going to
need to reskill more which is actually
more expensive right learning a wholly
new job and so i would love to see our
funding infrastructure
as well as our conversation around
higher ed and then most importantly our
higher ed entities but and some are
already doing this reorient their
business models and their ways of
teaching and their ways of working to
serve the every four economy
great
uh and david you have the last word what
would you want to leave us with
well
um
going back to k-12 for a minute i mean
your question about what would you
change i think we need a k-12 system in
which
we have
the people who run schools actually are
empowered to run schools rather than the
central office making all the hiring and
firing decisions and spending decisions
and
those schools
being allowed and encouraged to
diversify their learning models
particularly in urban areas where
geography's on your side kids families
actually have choices in terms of the
schools they can get to
um so that there are montessori schools
in there stem schools in their
performing arts schools and there are
dual language immersion schools and on
and on and on
and give the families choices
so that they can find this the school
that best fits their child
and then hold the schools accountable if
if the kids are learning in the fa the
parents are happy and the kids are happy
great
that school gets to keep going might
even be invited to create another school
to replicate
but
if the parents are gradually drifting
away taking their kids out and the test
scores are bad and the teachers
the parent surveys and student surveys
tell you that it's an unhappy place
well that school should be replaced by a
team that can do better in that building
so actual accountability for performance
um
i think
that's the kind of 21st century system
that that works and we know it works
because we have it in some places um
like new orleans uh which is all charter
now and like washington dc which is half
charter now
and denver where rachel is which has a
lot of charter schools and a lot of
innovation schools within the district
our districts are beginning to to put
their toes in that water but it's it's
awfully slow and we need more of it
all right great thanks well i hope we
see some of those changes we are in
desperate need of some improvements as
you both pointed out so thank you so
much for um talking with me
next week we'll discuss the ways that
work controls our lives and we'll be
joined by karen arnold head of talent
acquisition at automatic a company that
has always been fully remote
um thank you both again um and that's it
for this session
thank you brian thanks brian
[Music]